the biggest mistake that people make on
video is they start when they're most
anxious so when we're nervous we're
waiting for our Zoom to pop up or
waiting for our camera to be on we
taking a deep breath like this and we
say hi hey everyone typically it's
because they start really high in their
vocal range this is for both men and
women so right now I'm working very hard
to use the lowest end of my natural
range so hey good to see everyone those
are two totally different vocal
Impressions and the first 10 seconds of
a video you're going to lose someone
you're going to get someone speak on the
out breath do not hold your breath